foreign
the
brilliant Leia Halpern is tonight's
outsider
now in a world where so-called toxic
masculinity has left many blokes walking
on eggshells is it time we let men be
men in 2023 Leia certainly thinks so
heralding in the new year with this
hard-hitting tweet that read the lack of
masculine Role Models is the real
pandemic well that damning assessment
went viral it broke the internet
sparking a flood of replies that
supported her Theory including some men
who claimed being masculine was now a
crime and Leia joins me now hi Leia
hi great to be here I didn't know I was
Britain's spiciest woman I like that
thank you you most certainly are and I
hope you're going to get me to man up in
the course of this conversation
um have we simply gone too far in trying
to Stamp Out the few bad
um apples amongst the billions of men in
the world
yeah absolutely and I think it's really
sad um we live in this femcentric
Society whereby we have women raising
young boys and essentially raising them
in a way which raises them to be women
so if a young boy is competitive if he's
aggressive if he's a little bit
frustrated and he's fighting and he's
wrestling he's told that bad he's shamed
for being himself and told that that's
toxically masculine and he shouldn't do
that now that is incredibly dangerous we
also had the Gillette advert a few years
ago
um which shamed boys for the exact same
thing and I actually think that these
traits are so important these
competitive traits this is the traits of
aggression and frustration because this
is what's necessary in order for a man
to then progress and become the man that
he's supposed to be whether it's um to
build a business whether it's to you
know build muscle and become big and
strong and just to win in life These are
such important traits and unfortunately
taking those away
um Shea's boys were just being
themselves there's a reason why male
suicide is three times higher than um
girls throughout the United Kingdom and
it's because every time a man just is
doing what men are supposed to do he's
told that that's toxically masculine and
he shamed uh well that's right we've
just been talking about trans ideology
which in my view Leia is canceling and
erasing women but men in their own way
are being canceled too
yeah men are being canceled and I think
it's actually having a really bad
adverse effect because when men don't
have the opportunity to be men it leaves
this space a space for then women to
then have to get into their masculine
energy and rise up and fulfill that
space and women aren't happiest when
they're being men that they don't like
it women also repulsed by effeminate men
and men are repulsed by masculine women
and so they're just switching all the
genders around and it's sad it's ruining
the male female Dynamics we're going to
war with each other and I think it's
going to have very very disastrous
effects um with years to come uh men in
the 70s however Leia weren't great were
they in the pub all day expecting the
wife or girlfriend to do all the cooking
and cleaning and raise the kids wasn't
there room for improvement among these
real men
yeah I definitely think there's always
room for improvement and you know I
don't necessarily even look at the 50s
as you as the perfect time I think
things weren't good you know men were
cheating on their wives men didn't
appreciate the woman when she was
raising the children and creating this
beautiful home and so the pendulum has
swung so far the other way in order to
make up for this but I think that we're
getting to a point whereby we've gone so
far the other way we realize that that
doesn't work and now we're at a point
where men and women actually have this
opportunity to appreciate traditional
gender roles perhaps we will start to
move back the other way meet somewhere
in the middle and a man will actually
appreciate a woman who is creating a
beautiful home for him cleaning the
house making beautiful meals and the
women will really appreciate how hard it
is for the man to go out every single
day and provide you know he has stress
at work does he want to stress at home
too probably not and so I think it
teaches us this lesson
um and you know overall I could sort of
get into why this might be the case and
I think ultimately strong men are the
backbone of um Society I think it's the
men that go to war it's the men that
fight it's the men that protect the
women and the children and when you
feminize men and you don't have strong
men I think it's much easier for the
government to come in and push their
ideologies and indoctrinate the family
um so that's sort of my my analysis as
to why that might be happening Amen to
that Leia great to have you on the show
Leia help and do check her out on
Twitter a must read a very very uh
compelling commentator and the author of
undressing Bitcoin